[Music]
okay any time though
shut up
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and go my plan was to drive us
away
well your plan sucks
you're welcome
where are we trying to get motorbike
east side of the building
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you made a scene didn't you
[Music]
[Music]
what now we're getting out of here
[Applause]
go to the upper level
move your ass super soldier
[Music]
it still fits
oh my god
[Applause]
i never washed it once come and drink
workers
family back together again
um seeing as our family construct was
just a calculated rules that only lasted
three years i don't think that we can
use this
this term anymore can we agreed
so here's what's gonna happen okay
reunion then
huh and uh i want to say something right
off the bat
you haven't aged a day huh you're just
as beautiful and as supple as the day
they staged our marriage
you got fat but still good
the hell is that guy i was really
excited about tasmaster being
this formidable opponent as soon as
natasha
starts to experience the taskmaster's
fighting style
she's at a loss
he has the ability to mimic other
characters moves
from captain america black panther and
hawkeye
when you watch him i think you feel like
he's the ultimate secret weapon
pg-13 you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
i know you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world
i'm sorry we had our orders and we
played the
rules it wasn't real
it was real to me
[Music]
she's
one thing's for sure
i'm done running for my past
we've been waiting to tell the story of
natasha romanov for
years it was one of the great post
infinity saga opportunities how to
evolve
into phase four i'm done running from my
past
natasha is a product of all these films
that we've done
you will look at the past again in a new
light and we are sowing the seeds of new
characters into the future of the mcu
it's good to see it too sis
kevin's genius is that he thinks that
this really huge unexpected way
you know a lot about the characters
already so they're presumptions that you
bring to it
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
and we like to subvert those where your
plan sucks
marvel's created something absolutely
extraordinary
we're excited for people to go to
theaters to see and experience this
movie
in its place in the pantheon of the mcu
i made my choice
i'm dominating
you don't know everything about me the
avengers weren't my first family
it's important for us to understand how
this family
has shaped the person that natasha
became
natasha don't slouch i'm not slopping
listen to your mouth oh my god this is
up all right enough all of you i didn't
say anything
elena is the kind of little sister
character
she's there to get the job done and her
relationship with natasha
then becomes quite interesting because
they're constantly butting heads in the
way that siblings do
why do you always do that thing what
thing the pose
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser it's really fun to be able to
see those two characters when they're
together such a [ __ ]
it's good to see you too sis it was so
wonderful to be able to do this with
florence because she's such a wonderful
actor
feisty and fiery and just full of life
scarlet's been the leading female face
of these films for 10 years
that's definitely a cool badge to wear i
remember her daughter came to set one
day and i was like what does she think
you do and she goes
oh you know fight baddies for a living
and i was like but that is what you do
i like your best god i knew it i knew
you did it's so cool right
[Music]
you